superhero movies come out every few
months now but back in 1989 batman was
an event a milestone keep watching to
relive that special summer or live it
for the first time
on hearing that a batman film was on its
way fans of the dark knight did not have
their hopes up for one the campy 60s
batman series was still firmly
established in the pop culture canon
even as more gritty interpretations were
making their way to the comic book pages
unfortunately proving that nerd rage
over superhero castings pre-date social
media the news that beetlejuice himself
michael keaton had been cast as batman
didn't help matters to be fair the news
of keaton's casting stunned everyone not
just comic fans even batman executive
producer michael usland claims to have
initially thought the casting news was a
joke and trades like variety openly
mocked the choice fans started letter
writing campaigns to change the studio's
mind including petitions a little
disappointing because i guess if you're
growing up watching the comics and
reading comics and watching the tv show
it's
a lot different than i expected
considering how many fans will still
tell you keaton is their favorite batman
this kind of nerd rage may seem
inconceivable but before you judge think
about how the general public looked at
michael keaton in the 80s at the time
all of keaton's most commercially
successful films like beetlejuice and mr
mom were comedies so to understand how
batman fans felt hearing michael keaton
was playing batman just imagine if an
actor best known for his sitcom work was
cast in a superhero movie
the hype surrounding the release of
1989's batman is the stuff of legend all
you need for proof is the very existence
of so many online retrospectives not
necessarily about the film but
specifically the phenomena often
referred to as batmania at the time
created by warner brothers media machine
forbes scott mendelsohn writes about
being consciously gripped in bat fever
before the release of batman for comics
alliance patrick a reed recalls the
quote candy filled keaton heads in
supermarket checkout owls and the
batmobile toys and happy meals before
concluding that quote the entire world
had gone batty the washington post
remembers the hype transforming the film
into a pre-ordained event and as a
result yielding huge financial returns
it worked batman raked in 43 million
dollars in its opening weekend breaking
numerous ticket sales records including
breaking the record for ticket sales not
only on opening weekend but for its
second weekend too
one of the simplest and most effective
marketing tools used to publicize batman
was the golden black bat emblem that was
seemingly in every shop in 1989 whether
you were at the supermarket buying
groceries in a department store buying
clothes or a fast food joint getting
lunch the batman logo was everywhere
part of the genius of batman's marketing
onslaught was realizing how instantly
iconic that bat logo already was it was
not at all uncommon for example to be
met with the movie posters which didn't
even include the name batman but simply
the black and gold bat logo and the
release date june 23rd paul levitz dc
comics executive vice president and
publisher in 1989 joked that the bat
logo shirts were so successful that it
caused a shortage of black cotton the
notion of using a superhero's logo
similarly in marketing has since become
practically mandatory but in 1989 it was
a novel and effective use of iconic
imagery
released the same month as batman the
late prince's hit single bat dance was
as inescapable as any other bat related
hype that summer at turns a chaotic
dance song or a slow funky groove bat
dance is liberally peppered with samples
from the film including arguably the
joker's most surprising exclamation
the single got a lot of negative reviews
from critics but it still hit the top of
the billboard charts in august 1989 and
the video like the song is striking wild
and kind of incoherent
prince appears both as himself in kind
of a bat kv music studio and as a
character known as gemini who appears to
be half batman and half joker along with
stoking the already raging fire of bat
hype bat dance was a huge win for prince
the video won a soul train award and
helped make prince's batman soundtrack
his first number one album since 1985's
around the world in a day
the notion that batman is a darker hero
shouldn't feel like a revelation right
in the 21st century if a new batman
project is announced you can expect a
gravelly voice vigilante who makes
himself a friend to shadows he broods he
mourns and he finds gargoyles to perch
on wherever he goes it may surprise
younger fans to know however that before
tim burton's batman the dark knight's
legacy was dominated by the camp of the
60s batman series
sure the fans of the source material
knew gotham's greatest champion had
wider variety in his stories than simply
the over-the-top parodies found in the
television show but outside the comic
book shop most audiences heard the name
batman and thought of adam west and bird
ward climbing up walls or their
ridiculous fistfights with the comic
book sound effects like pow and biff
superimposed over the melee curing pop
culture of this association was one of
the goals of lifelong batman fan michael
usland in his decade-long crusade to get
batman made in the shadows of the bat
documentary useland says for about 20
years whenever anyone mentioned the word
batman hal zap and wham were always
attached to the name i wanted to detach
it and get back to the heart of the
character
considering the hero's more contemporary
adaptations it's clear 1989's batman
succeeded in forcing the hero away from
his days dancing the battusi
just as batman forced audiences to deal
with a dark knight who was far more
interested in vengeance than he was in
puns jack nicholson's portrayal of the
joker made the world take the cackling
maniac seriously while he may seem
cartoonish compared to grittier 21st
century portrayals of the joker
nicholson had a take on the character
that was a steep departure from what
most audiences expected sure by 1989
alan moore and brian boland's batman the
killing joke was making waves at the
comic book shop but the live action
joker most people knew was played by
cesar romero in the 60s batman series
not only did romero famously refuse to
even shave his mustache for the role but
we are in no danger of being
contradicted when we point out that the
hero of 1989's batman kills more people
in that film than romero's joker does in
the entire 60 series
there's no better proof that nicholson
is largely responsible for the more
complex directions joker has taken in
more contemporary times than the
complaints of the guy who played him for
two years when the associated press
asked for his reaction to the 1989 film
cesar romero called it quote dreary
romero lamented
nicholson who is such a wonderful actor
and who has done such good work is just
so violent
while there will probably always be
naysayers the stories of comic book
superheroes slogged a long road toward
any kind of legitimacy and 1989's batman
was one of the biggest steps down that
road in the shadows of the bat
documentary michael usland gives an
example of how superhero comics reviewed
pre-batman that still would sound
familiar to any fan of the genre while
attending indiana university in the 70s
useland took advantage of a program that
allowed students to pitch courses that
they would teach themselves usland says
when he applied to teach a course about
comic book heroes the college dean told
him comic books were cheap entertainment
and junk not worthy of academic study
according to useland he responded by
illustrating how the origin story of
superman mirrored that of the biblical
figure moses and as a result his course
was immediately approved
batman's success not only helped
legitimize superhero movies but made
them more attractive to actors and
directors speaking about this to the
washington post andrew farago author and
curator for san francisco's cartoon art
museum listed visionary directors who
would later attach themselves to
superhero franchises aptly wondering who
could have imagined a world with kenneth
branagh directing thor
along with their many easter eggs
contemporary superhero movies and tv
shows are known for teasing fans by
introducing characters who should the
adaptation follow the source material
closely enough could become superheroes
or villains and future stories for
example 2008's iron man hinted at james
rhodes becoming the armored hero war
machine but fans had to wait one more
movie for it
next time baby
batman gave us a very early example of
this kind of tease by casting billy d
williams as hero district attorney
harvey deck any dc comics fan in the
theater knew that dent was destined to
become the coin tossing criminal to face
with this character's appearance the
movie created a palpable sense among
fans that there was more to come and did
it without pandering or shouting the
reference from the rooftops and while
the part would eventually be recast with
tommy lee jones the franchise did end up
making good on its promise of adding
two-face to batman's rogues gallery in
batman forever williams meanwhile
eventually got to play the role of
two-face decades later in the lego
batman movie of all places
batman also created the delicious sense
that there was more on the way through
its many absences it was impossible to
not ask who would play robin who would
play riddler or who would play penguin
when he eventually showed up fans were
casting the sequels before the original
was out of theaters and it was in
theaters a long time
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you